The next background technology that I'm telling
about is software RAID. I mentioned that hardware
RAID has two problems. The first problem being
small writes and we said we can get
rid of the small write problem by using
log structure file systems. But the hardware RAID
also has another problem and that is it
is employing multiple hardware drives. And hardware RAID,
generally speaking, is very expensive proposition. On the
other hand, in a local area network, we
have lots of compute power distributed over the
LAN and every node on the LAN has
associated with it are disks. So could we
not use the disks that are available on
local data network for doing exactly the same
thing that we did with hardware RAID? And that
is, stripe a file across the disks of all the nodes that are in the
local area network. So that's the idea behind the Zebra file system that was
built at UC Berkeley, which was the first one to experiment with this software
RAID technology. It combines both lock structure
file system and the RAID technology, lock-structured file
system in order to get rid of the small write problem, and the RAID technology
to get the parallelism you want in a file server to be able to read from the
disks in parallel, so that you can reduce
the latency for serving client requests. The idea
here is that you're going to use commodity
hardware available as nodes connected to disks on
a local area network. And since LFS, lock
structured file system, is good for getting rid of
the small write problem, we are going to employ
LFS as the technology for the file server. So
in this case, what we have are not data
files but we have log segments that have to
be written out to the disk in an LFS. And what we're going to do is we're going
to stripe the log segment on multiple nodes
of the disks in software and that is the
RAID technology. So if this is a log segment
that represents the changes made to several different files
on a particular client node, then the software
RAID, what it will do, is then take this
log segment and stripe it. Part one of the
log segment on this node, part two on this,
part three on this, part four on this and the ECC that corresponds to these four
parts of the log segments into a fifth drive. That's the idea
in software RAID. Exactly similar to the
hardware RAID except software is doing this
striping of the log segment on multiple nodes available in a local area network.